lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
hablar un poco sobre identidades
polinomiales y esta es solamente una
forma sofisticada de saber si una
expresión que involucra un polinomio es
igual a otra expresión quizás ya estén
familiarizados con x cuadrada más 2 x
más 1 ya hemos visto polinomios así
muchas veces esta es una cuadrática y
pueden reconocer que esto es igual a x +
1 al cuadrado que para cualquier valor
de x x cuadrada más 2 x 1
es lo mismo que sumar 1 a esa equis y
elevar todo al cuadrado esto lo vimos
cuando aprendimos por primera vez a
multiplicar binomios y elevar binomios
al cuadrado pero ahora veremos esto con
expresiones un poquito más complicadas
cosas que no son cuadrados simples y que
no son tan obvias como esto la forma en
que demostraremos si esto se cumple o no
es con un poco de manipulación
algebraica por ejemplo si se les acerca
a alguien en la calle y les pregunta m
al cubo menos 1 es igual a m
1 x
no más m más m al cuadrado pausa en el
vídeo y piensen en qué es lo que le
responderían a esta persona si pueden
demostrar que es o no una identidad
polinomiales vamos a resolverlo juntos
la forma en que yo resolvería esto es
multiplicar lo que está del lado derecho
por lo que esto es igual a como está m y
la multiplicó por cada término de esta
segunda expresión m por 1s m m por m es
m cuadrada y m por m cuadrada es m a la
tercera potencia y ahora tomo este menos
1 y lo distribuyó por cada término en la
segunda expresión menos uno por uno es
menos uno menos uno por m es menos m
menos uno por m al cuadrado es menos m
cuadrada ahora veamos si podemos
simplificar lo tenemos una m y una m
negativa se cancelan y una m cuadrada
negativa que también se cancelan por lo
que nos queda m a la tercera potencia
menos uno claramente m al cubo menos uno
a m al cubo menos 1 para cualquier valor
de m
estas son expresiones idénticas por lo
que esto es una identidad polinomio
hagamos otro ejemplo digamos que se nos
acerca a otra persona en la calle y nos
dice rápido n 3 al cuadrado más 12 n es
igual a 8 n 13 es una identidad
polinomiales pausa en el vídeo y traten
de responder a esto muy bien vamos a
resolverlo juntos
voy a resolverlo de la misma forma vamos
a simplificar esto con un poco de
álgebra y quizá la forma más sencilla de
hacerlo y podemos hacerlo de varias
formas es fijarnos en estos términos con
n este 2 n iv es de 8 n y vamos a quitar
el 2 n del lado izquierdo
si restamos los n en ambos lados de la
ecuación nos queda del lado izquierdo n
3 al cuadrado y del lado derecho queda 6
n 8 ene - 2 n 13 a que es igual
n 3 al cuadrado es igual a n al cuadrado
dos veces tres por n y si lo que acabo
de hacer
no les parece familiar los invito a que
vean los videos acerca de elevar
binomios al cuadrado esto es igual a 6 n
más 3 al cuadrado que es 9 y esto es
igual a 6 n 13 bueno esto comienza a
verse medio extraño pero sigamos con el
álgebra si restamos 6 n en ambos lados
que nos queda del lado izquierdo queda
encuadrada + 9 y del lado derecho queda
13 ahora existen valores de n para los
cuales esto no se cumpla por supuesto se
me ocurren muchos valores de n para los
que esta igualdad no se cumple si en es
1 esto no se cumple si n es 2 esto si se
cumple pero si n estrés
esto no se cumple 100 es 45 etcétera
esto no se cumple y lo mismo sucede para
la mayoría de los valores de n para
poder tener una identidad polinomio
la igualdad se tiene que cumplir para
todos los valores legítimos conozco
podemos evaluar a la variable en
cuestión por lo que esto de aquí no es
una identidad polinomio y terminamos